carmen comme à l'opéra mais pourtant ici
nous sommes dans la salle polyvalente de
ruminghem 11 cents habitants alors ne
vous étonnez pas si vous rencontrez des
militaires des curés de jeunes ouvrières
qui vous rappellent un autre siècle
j'interprète unis gagnent officiers un
lieutenant qui fait partie des nombreux
amoureux de carmen je fais le remendado
c'est-à-dire un compte rond point de vue
ne vous étonnez pas si vous rencontrez
les enfants de ruminghem métamorphosé ou
encore un metteur en scène exalté début
j'ai dit oui c est possible de faire
c'est génial ça nous force de te trouver
des solutions ça nous fout ça me force
d'être original
original est fou ce carmen à la campagne
interpréter essentiellement par des
amateurs prend vite des airs d'opéra de
poche
on a exactement cinquante six mètres
carrés d'espacé et 56 m² on met un piano
qui fait un mètre 87
nous avons 25 choristes 10 solistes des
figurants il faut qu'on arrive à caser
c'est du carmen de proximité mais quand
c'est comme ça directement quand les
gens ont l'impression de pouvoir vous
touché c'est énorme pour le public et si
vous ressentez les élans de cette jeune
femme pleine de vie si vous percevez la
douleur de ces amoureux ou encore si les
dialogues vous semble si juste ne vous
étonnez pas ce que je veux c'est être
libre
l'opéra le plus joué au monde a tout
simplement retrouver ici un peu de sa
fraîcheur originelle